foreign
Jade and Jacob elordi were just spotted
together following reports the two had
called it quits meanwhile a source tells
ET that following the College admission
Scandal Olivia is doing really well and
her priorities have changed I just have
such a big guard up and I'm so afraid to
like let any sort of wall down back in
August rumor swirled that Olivia and
Jacob had split after a few months of
dating but one month later the two were
snapped together walking his dog in L.A
and on Tuesday Olivia and Jacob were
spotted again this time at a park in L.A
that's Jacob keeping it cash in a gray
hoodie Shades black sweatpants and white
sneakers and Olivia she kept it cozy
Chic in a white jacket with peace
patches and gym shoes I don't think we
ever have to do something like crazy
fancy or something extraordinary to have
a fun time and while the status of their
relationship is unknown a source is
dishing to ET about how Olivia and her
famous family are doing more than three
years after the College admission
Scandal I do want them to have somewhat
of a normal you know finish out high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I really want that
for them fans will recall that Olivia's
mom Fuller house star Lori Lachlan
served two months in prison in 2020
after pleading guilty to one count of
conspiracy to commit wire and mail fraud
meanwhile Lori's husband Massimo gianuli
was sentenced to five months in prison
after pleading guilty to one count of
conspiracy to commit wire and mail fraud
and honest Services wire and mail fraud
I just want them to have that experience
and get that education and have a degree
to fall back on the two were accused of
paying 500 thousand dollars in bribes to
get Olivia and her older sister Bella
admitted to the University of Southern
California as recruits for the crew team
even though neither of them participated
in the sport they tried to sign up as a
coxswain someone who steers the boat
tried to get her to have pictures of her
and an ERG and this is all done in email
Communications that showed that they
were trying to build literally a
portfolio to show that she was quote a
real athlete now a source tells E.T
Olivia and Bella are doing really well
adding that their friends have stood by
their side through all the drama quote
their friends didn't abandon them and if
anything the support their Inner Circle
showed during that time just
strengthened their relationships there's
a lot more attention than I think we
ever expected following the Scandal both
Olivia and her sister dropped out of USC
now a source tells E.T the two have
grown from The Experience adding that
their priorities have changed and they
have become more humble and hard-working
quote the Scandal definitely shifted
their trajectories a bit but they are
still both very entrepreneurial and are
focused on being successful and making
their dreams come true moving on and
moving forward and and life goes on as
for their parents ET sour says Lori and
Massimo are supportive of their
daughters I want them to be happy so I
want to be supportive of everything they
want to do and the family overall is in
a good place
[Music]